I'm super excited about this event and
I'm having both dr. site doctor side a
Dean C Flores and dr. Tanya Dundas with
us today and I'm gonna do a brief
presentation on each one but before I
start I would like to thank the
divisional Dean of the humanities Amy
Hungerford for the support of the 320
York humanities grant administered by
Matthew Jacobson of the public
humanities support and also for the
support especially for the support of
the Center for raising the unity and
transnational migration it's director
Steven P D and our amazing staff Matthew
tonico and nandi Cummings who have done
so much of the coordination to make this
possible and they have just gone way
beyond the call of duty here so first I
want to introduce dr. Tanner nandus dr.
Tony Hernandez is a professor of law at
Fordham University School of Law where
she teaches comparative employment
discrimination critical race theory and
Trust and states she received her BA
from Brown University and her JD from up
the street at the Yale Law School where
she served as no topics editor of the
Yale Law Journal she has served as a
faculty fellow at the Institute for
Research on women at Rutgers University
and as a scholar in residence at the
Schomburg Center for research in black
culture in 2009 professor Hernandez was
elected to the American Law Institute
and in 2006 oh seven Hispanic business
magazine selected her as one of the
hundred most influential Hispanics they
call professor Hernandez scholarly
interest is in the study of comparative
race relations and anti-discrimination
law and her work in the area has been
published in the California Law Review
Cornell Law Review Harvard civil rights
civil liver liberties Law Review and the
Yale Law Journal amongst other
publications as a law and public affairs
fellow at Princeton dr. Hernandez
conducted research on the topic of
Latino inter-ethnic racism in the
workplace and it
implications for the inform enforcement
of employment discrimination law her new
book which we have actually book order
forms for an encourage you to look at
them her new book multiracial and civil
rights mixed rate erase stories of
discrimination was published by NYU
press in 2018 just last year in this
recent book professor Hernandez explores
the question of how to pursue racial
equality in a growing multiracial world
the growth of a mixed-race population
has led some commentators to proclaim
that multi racial discrimination is
distinct in nature from the racial
discrimination that non multiracial
persons experience and that as a
consequence a whole new approach to
civil rights law is required and she
talks about this and challenges
different approaches to this idea dr.
Hernandez describes her own experience
as an after latina mixed-race person and
then shares how she tracks down the
court case narratives of multi racial
discrimination and the story of racial
privilege they revealed in this in this
book she does that the stories she
uncovered are especially timely and
coming at a time when explicit racism is
resurfacing and dr. Hernandez looks at
multi racial discrimination cases and
this look is essential for fortifying
the focus of civil rights law on racial
privilege I also want to introduce dr.
cited in C Flores
dr. Vincent Flores is associate
professor in the department's of Latino
and Caribbean studies and sociology at
Rutgers University New Brunswick where
she teaches courses in urban studies
architecture and urban planning social
inequality space race and space place
and the build environment Latin American
and Caribbean housing policy and the
African diaspora professor Dean's in
Florida Flores earned her BA in
sociology from Harvard University and MA
in sociology from Stanford and a
master's in urban planning and PhD in
sociology and Social Policy from the
University of Michigan professor Dean C
Flores
research focuses focuses on
understanding how urban space mediates
community life and race class and social
inequality she uses an interdisciplinary
lens mixed-method approaches and often a
comparative Caribbean us framework to
investigate the processes that cement
the build environment and an equally
distribute power her book locked in
locked out gated communities in a Puerto
Rican city was published by University
of Pennsylvania press in 2013 and was
the winner of the prestigious Robert E
Park award of the community urban
sociology section of the American
Sociological Association in 2014 and an
honorable mention of the 2014 Frank
Bonilla book award of the Puerto Rican
Studies Association locked in lock out
examines race and class inequality as
they are created contained and
negotiated through urban policy the
physical build environment and community
gates in private and public housing dr.
Dean C Flores is currently working on a
number of projects the first is a mixed
method examination of how race is
articulated in residential real estate
practices in demographically changing
neighborhoods in Brooklyn New York and
the second looks at the transatlantic
circulation of housing planning and
design ideals in the middle of the 20th
century
she is also collaborating on a mobile
data project with department and
university colleagues seeking to
understand racial segregation as it
occurs in motion and a mixed-media
project on the construction of the
Caribbean professor Dean C Flores has
held fellowships at the University of
Pennsylvania Institute for urban
research and also has been a fellow of
the Andrew W Mellon postdoctoral program
on raised crime and justice and of the
Vera Institute for justice of justice
since 2013 professor DC Flores has been
a board member of the mayoral appointed
board of the New York City Housing
Authority and I would like for us to
give them both a warm welcome to talk to
us today
and before I actually end which I will
do very quickly promise I just wanted to
say that we after both of our speakers
our speakers talk we will have some
commentary by two of our undergraduate
here Yale alejandro comas short and
Alondra Mejia and I just briefly wanted
to tell you that this that the reason
why this is being done today here is
because of students like them they have
expressed powerful consistent interest
in Ephrata nyada's of various kinds as
well as on blackness in diasporic
context and specifically they have been
interest in anti blackness in latina
communities which is a topic that they
raised in various informal and formal
forums and which they have great both
personal and academic intellectual
interest so I really appreciate them
taking the time to be here as a
representative of other students who are
likewise very interested in this in this
topic and I'll leave it at that
and thank you very much it's a pleasure
to be back I took advantage of three
years at Law School who I never went to
the by Nikki I went to the by Nikki for
the first time today uh it's quite
lovely so what I want to do is share a
few words about the background of the
book but if I was up there um anyway but
my one meager attempt it's a media
interpretation of a sake
well it's not really that important this
way never do a PowerPoint all I have for
you is just one image that's it the
cover to the book and it's no problem to
proceed without it okay no problem
okay I just closed this them hmm so that
you don't have distraction okay so what
I thought I would do is uh share a few
words about the background of the book
multiracial and civil rights before I
read a short excerpt for you and it's
about my own personal story so you're
getting a exposure to the book that I
don't normally do in scholarly
presentations because I think my
colleagues weren't that kind of business
about me they should buy the book yeah
uh-huh but for students
I have special love I make a special
consideration of I've been a civil
rights professor lawyer etc for over 25
years
and yet I was very confused when I
started reading as some commentary about
the rise of people who identify as
multiracial that I didn't confuse me the
part that confused me was an attribution
that that rise in this more fluid
nuanced context base form of identifying
racially now meant that we needed a
whole new civil rights and the reason
why that confused me is because it
didn't seem in keeping with what I was
observing but I decided you know what
let me go take a look at these cases and
see for myself what's going on since
these commentators are now sort of
alerting me to a new dynamic
so I go back I take a look at these
cases and what I see is that while there
certainly is a presence of people who
are now identifying as mixed race and
they say that before the court or they
say hello my name is X and my racial
identity is Y and this is what happened
to me and when they begin with what
happened to them the mixed race identity
then takes a back seat in their own
stories their stories are about being
unfairly treated not based on merit
excluded from public opportunities of
access all because of them being lumped
as non-white not about any particular
form of there
I think meaning that their personal
identity doesn't match up necessarily
with what the more crude group based
form of treatment that they're receiving
yet in this literature of these
commentators courts are presumed to
misunderstand the nature of
discrimination against mixed-race
persons and this is when I wanted a
better comprehend so when I looked at
all of these I did it within the housing
context and point in context public
accommodations a criminal justice
education and and in all of these
various spheres I found a very
particular dynamic right that I'm going
to describe to you and with that dynamic
this focus on non whiteness of any sort
being problematic by those who want to
discriminate what I observed was a need
for reinforcement of our current
structures of civil rights and
anti-discrimination law as opposed to a
justification for sort of rewriting the
page so let me sort of start with an
excerpt from the book from the very
beginning where I look at how the
multiracial stories that I dug into
because this is basically what I did I
looked at people's personal stories as
evolved in court cases but still their
personal stories and in looking at all
those personal stories I have
say that it sort of brought me back to
my own as an alpha latina mixed-race
person sort of navigating various tropes
and pathologies of mestizaje of racial
mixture pride in Latino communities and
it seemed important to be transparent
about how that background was informing
my own analysis okay
just before I begin how many of you
understand Spanish oh okay there's a
couple in here that I loosely try to
translate but if you all think this is a
better translation feel free to shout it
out okay so I'm gonna start reading I'm
not doing from the book itself because
the font is too small
all these 25 years old you know they
have taken a toll on the Iceman okay so
I've got it all printed out nice in the
big farmer
I am the mixed-race daughter of a
mixed-race mother almost given away
because of her blackness in the 1940s my
maternal grandmother Lucretia was a
mixed-race country girl or what her
fellow Puerto Ricans called a he betta
from a mountain village and what the
people her African ancestry appeared
slightly in what they describe as a
three Enya light wheat color skin tone
but was not very apparent in her facial
features or hair texture her older
sisters were similarly light-skinned and
favored their fair complected mother
more than their darker skinned father
for this reason Lucretia and her sisters
considered themselves a race apart from
those who appeared more unambiguously
afro-descendant any tinge of color and
the family was attributed to the long
ago legacy of by you know Indians on the
island and it was immaterial to the
family that by you know Indians have
been historically documented to have
been exterminated by the Spaniards but
late 16th century make the late 16th
century when my grandmother Lucretia
fell in love with and United herself
with a carpenter and a
tarus name one her family was not
pleased not because of his profession
but because while he was a mixed-race
grandchild of a former slave and a son
of an afro Puerto Rican mother and white
Spaniard his race mixture appearance was
what Lu gracias family labelled as black
and fuss unacceptable
Puerto Rican identity may claim to
celebrate racial mixture but some of us
are thought to look more mixed than
others dark-skinned deviations from the
idealization of light-skinned with
European features and straight hair are
ejected from the Puerto Rican portrait
of racial mixture Lucretia's family was
no exception from Miss Puerto Rican and
similarly Latin American and Thai black
conception of racial mixture Lucretia
second child Nina my mom was born in the
1940s and much of this may of Lucretia's
family to them
the child was dark too dark too dark to
count as racially mixed and certainly
too dark to pass as white or white
Puerto Rican baby Nina did not best past
the look behind the ears
Caribbean tests of seeking up the future
darkness of infants because you know our
skin changes over time even more
problematic
Nina's skin tone approximating that of
1940s African American singer and
actress Lena Horne perhaps the Beyonce
of her time for you Millennials would
complicate the family's image as
disassociated from blackness who she
what is she to you
in other words the campaign to send baby
Nina away began in earnest Lucas his
family lobbied to have baby Nina placed
for adoption with an African American
family any African American family would
do so long as baby Nina was removed from
the household only later as an adult
researcher would I learn from a
colleague how much the family impulse
to return dark-skinned children like
they are damaged goods in the foster
care system in Porto Rico when they
become too dark was like what happened
with my family at the same time the
families animus towards the Afro Puerto
Rican father that baby Nina favored did
not extend to her older sister Monica
with the same father why a difference
Monica
although sibling was lighter in
complexion with long straight hair
Monica's African ancestry then did not
announce itself so loudly in her
appearance and she was immediately
accepted by the family the physical
comparisons between the two sisters was
a constant obsession of the family with
Nina a dark one being called
monito little monkey and negative in bay
little little black African like girl my
best translation while Monica was
lovingly called La Nina the little girl
the loving little girl
Nina's darker skin tone and African
tresses were always viewed as
problematic by the family her kinky
curls what they call Bella Malo bad hair
was a source of consternation that
compelled Lucas's family to continually
shave Nina's hair in the hope that it
would grow out straighter I told you
they were country people any infraction
of Lucas's rules of discipline were
greeted with both a beating and an
expression of regret for not having
given her away to an african-american
family at birth along with a threat to
place Nina in a foster home again this
was a marked contrast to the indulgence
accorded to her older sister Monica with
the slightly lighter skin and more
importantly better Lindell pretty hair
literally more coach we better
translated as good hair the racialized
distinctions between the two girls
continued their entire lives my own
childhood experience with differential
treatment based on however mixed or
black someone perceived me to look on
any given day
text-only reinforce my understanding of
the relevance of anti-black sentiment
within celebrations of idealized notions
of mixture amongst Puerto Ricans and
others
my grandmother Luka Zia was never
happier than when my hair was greased
down into two long braids down my back
and I looked as what she fantasized and
indigenous Spain I would look like what
our absolute preference for was for me
to have my hair blow-dried straight
regardless of how short and duration
they look with last my curl the girls in
the room know what I'm talking about all
right one day in humid weather maybe a
week with some big rollers dry air
nightly wrapping for maximum stretch
however the hair wars began in earnest
with her when I cut off my hair in an
act of adolescent independence so much
shorter than it is right now my
grandmother was mystified as to why I
would choose to have my curls a spring
out on display in what resembled to my
mother's afro in my grandmother's eyes
my mother was unfortunately afflicted
with overtly bad hair but why in the
world would I choose to emulate that
style when I had what she thought was
the benefit of being better situated to
beat my hair into submission with a more
effective a simulation of whiteness
every visit to her apartment on the
Lower East Side of Manhattan was greeted
with some version of iesson Villa oh
that hair hmm
oh boy oh boy say pelo why don't you do
something with that hair we're in my
hair in a short curly mop also worked to
seemingly eject me from my presume
membership in the Latino latina --xe
I'm with young people imaginary
encountering la fenix merchants and
other lesbian acts service providers I
was now constantly greeted with a
surprise oh you speak Spanish hmm
where did you learn to speak Spanish by
hair now barred me and barred the door
to my automatic
entre to let the next complication I now
had to earn my way back into Latin
honest by constantly speaking Spanish
loudly and referencing my latina culture
like in Latin America the imagined
Latino community has and had a decided
vision of mixture that does not
encompass tightly coiled hair with brown
skin the anti blur anti black slurs I
also heard use in Latino community
with respect to African Americans only
reinforced my early impressions that
blackness was problematic despite our
assertions of Latino pride and being a
mixture of races it became evident to me
that our cultural mestizaje pride race
mixture pride notwithstanding not all
parts of the mixture were equally
welcomed or celebrated even outside the
family nucleus I found that there was a
politics to racial mixture that living
in the multi-ethnic New York City of the
late 1960s and 70s did not abate I was
blessed to have attended a very dynamic
headstart program located in the Midtown
West neighborhood of Manhattan then
known as Hell's Kitchen the backdrop for
the movie in the play West Side Story
get a little image there ok
the prisons the preschool what is it
incredibly diverse and a delight to
attack however when we all graduated
preschool and entered into the local
public elementary together I was
separated from my diverse group of
friends for the first two weeks of first
grade I found myself in her a chaotic
classroom where we were often left
unattended and where very little
learning took place this was the special
education class of the 1960s the class
was filled with brown skinned Latinos
and African Americans I'd never met
before I was separated from my preschool
best friend Lizzie with a sweet white
Irish face I was separated from my
Puerto Rican buddy hooing with his pale
white skin nor were any of the other
lighter skinned Puerto Ricans from head
start in special ed
in class with me when my mother
discovered that something was not right
about my elementary school learning
situation she intervened I guess what we
now called helicoptered in and the
school official claimed I was placed
there because of my Spanish language
education needs this is an explanation
that was most peculiar a given one the
English dominant African Americans in
the class and the absence of any
bilingual education offered while I was
there back then there was not a public
conversation about the school to Prison
Pipeline but there was certainly a
penitentiary approach to warehousing
difference only when my mother insisted
that English was actually my primary
language and the language of my
instruction in preschool was I able to
enter a nation classroom where actual
teaching took place even after my escape
boat from the special ed of the 1960s
which was neither special nor an
education hmm my New York City public
school experiences continued to operate
within a pigment aa cracy a higher gift
color where the racial mixture of
Latinos was acknowledged but closer
approximations of whiteness were
rewarded with presumptions of competence
and intellect this became especially
clear to me when strangers did not know
my Spanish surname or ethnic origin they
just saw the face and presumed that my
black/white mixture was solely due to an
african-american ancestry after a
lifetime of seeing how my mixed-race and
multi-ethnic Status multilingual status
did not shield me from the racism of our
society nor many others I have since
been blessed to travel to it came as a
surprise to me to read the work of legal
scholars and others proclaiming that
mixed race racial discrimination was
distinct in nature from the racial
discrimination that non multiracial
identified persons experience while
certainly every individual perceives
their racial discrimination as their own
personal experience and I'm aware I did
each
clients is unique it's still a jolt to
encounter the premise of the presume
uniqueness of the discrimination
entirely against multiracial identify
persons and its requirement that a new
approach to civil rights be formulated
because this presumption is such a
disconnect from my own mixed-race puerto
rican experience i began the journey of
tracking down the multiracial accounts
of racism for myself the tale of why
multi racial discrimination is fought to
challenge traditional understandings of
civil rights law has a lot to teach us
about how to move towards a more
egalitarian society it's my hope that
the insights i found in examining the
multi racial discrimination cases will
be illuminating for you as well whatever
your own story of race may be so that
closes the excerpt do i have a few more
minutes left or should i closer i do
okay so the book examines all
electronically available
anti-discrimination law cases with
mixed-race identified claimants or so
not every single person who has any
racial mixture in their background the
inquiry the focus of the research was on
people I identify self identify with
their mix Rea status because that's two
different things and I looked at their
stories within the context of the
workplace school settings housing
discrimination more about that later
after dr. Flores doctors right public
accommodations and criminal justice and
what I found in each of those contexts
was a story after story of a very
familiar white versus non-white bias
I assure you a sample of a story from
the book right so you don't just say
about a woman named Jill Mitchell Jim
Mitchell describes herself as a
light-skinned biracial woman with a
black father and a white mother she says
that based on her appearance many people
presume that she's mixed usually looking
eyeliner
but she says when they guess they often
guess that she's a mix of some latina
with European ancestry hmm
so she starts working for champs sports
sporty good chain her chain was in
Beaumont Texas just to give you a little
flavor she still works there's the
full-time management trainee she works
there for a whole year without any
problems
she actually receives positive
performance evaluations but she felt
that her entire works experience began
to shift once her store manager
discovered that her racial background
while mix was okay for years as being
mixed but that it included African
ancestry now how do you find this out
she didn't disclose this on her job
application she didn't answer his
question you know makes for a super gay
so what are you she an answer that
because there's not his business it's
also an illegal question but any case so
he doesn't know about her background
from her he figures it out so to speak
when after year working there her family
starts to show up after work to pick her
Rob give her a drive home meet her at
lunch
take her out to lunch etc and some of
the family members have showed up with
the darker-skinned members of the family
so what he did the question out who are
they and what are they to you and she
says that their family is that a brain
works and he comes to the logical
conclusion you're not adapted then I
guess oh this is part of your background
as well hmm
so he deduces like that her racial
background includes some African
ancestry she says that his attitude
towards her change dramatically those
are her words as he fixated on her
African ancestry he starts to make
negative remarks to her about black
people and on one occasion eve is what a
confronts are very directly as to why
was it she was only dating black men we
viewed that as problematic a little
intersectional analysis here hmm at one
point Mitchell over here's the manager
stating we need to get her out of here
and sure enough this racialized
treatment of her continues
she is eventually demoted and her former
position is filled with a white employee
who came not from the ranks of the
established management trainee program
but from one of the part-time hires like
cousin the pointers taught me to come up
front now and be a manager as a result
she attributes logically her demotion
therese discrimination and she files a
claim
now her chances for winning her lawsuit
were quite low not because of the
relative merits of her claim because but
because it has been documented that very
few complaints of racial discrimination
in our contemporary times every yield of
success for claimants the vast majority
of racial discrimination cases are
dismissed by courts without even the
opportunity to get to trial hmm from
1979 to 2006 just give me a quick little
glimpse top federal claimants only 115
percent 15 percent of all job
discrimination cases and this is my
comparison to all other civil cases
meaning non criminal cases where the win
rate is 51 percent we so don't come back
to me oh it isn't all people know not
all plaintiffs lives commentators
attribute the low success rate of
employment discrimination or
anti-discrimination law cases with the
growing hostility with which courts
approach allegations of discrimination
my judges sort of seemingly believe that
the passage of the civil rights laws
alone have wrought a post-racial society
in which instances of discrimination are
rare but despite the overarching
challenge of persuading courts that an
instance of discrimination actually
occurred Jill
files a motion for court-appointed
counsel and the court grants it we step
back for a moment to give you a little
Law School preview for any my pre-law
people in the room you are only entitled
to an attorney in a criminal case New
York now has a little extra deception
out for housing discrimination that's
separate across the nation you only get
a lawyer paid for by the government if
you have a criminal case because your
liberty is at stake several cases you're
on your own but she goes forward and she
says I want I need a lawyer and I'd like
for you to
point went to me and for the government
to pay for it when I tell my legal
colleagues about this they're like
flabbergasted one that he made the boss
asked for it and to think the court
grants it and he grants it with the
notation that the merits of her claims
wait in favor of granting the motion
this is quite a victory in the context
of the contemporary judicial animosity
to any discrimination claim here the
court sort of endorsing some sort of
implicitly her the merits of a claim and
expending an investment on the part of
the government to allow her to have a
level playing field meaning have another
lawyer
talk to the employers lawyer right to be
able to talk power to power have a look
a claim it have a lawyer has significant
consequences right when you level this
playing field there's a little
conversation that takes place after that
she gets her lawyer appointed to her and
they settle the claim out of court right
so meaning she is provided with some
settlement to try to make her home now
that is a win within the context and
here I'm gonna close of anti of
anti-discrimination law in short here
the judge is not confused by her claim
right nor by her by racial identity and
she's able to reach a satisfactory
resolution of her case within
traditional civil rights law now at its
core her story is one about the societal
bias against all non-whites as a post of
anti racial mixture bias and that's the
pattern and all the multi racial
discrimination cases but that I found
now what is interesting is that these
commentators find the case problematic
nonetheless I look at all cases but I
start off with theirs in order to sort
of see when people are winning weren't
they thinking that's a good thing and
the reason why they don't like this case
even though Jill wins is because the
court constantly refers to her as black
right he describes what her identity is
but then he oversimplifies
i didn'ti in his legal analysis and for
these commentators that
oversimplification is an indictment on
what the court does now I'll close by
simply saying in a perfect world it
would be preferable for judges to
reflect back to claim it the personal
identity right that they set out at the
outset maybe just as a matter of
courtesy but is it a legally flawed
analysis when the court doesn't do so
here the judge focuses on her blackness
in the same way that her story does put
that in your aunt think on it we'll talk
more in the Q&A
[Applause]
[Music]
hi so that was a thrill to listen to and
I think many points of conversation in
the presentation I'm gonna take a little
bit of different approach rather
academic approach so bear with me here I
will get to myself sometime in the
presentation but I won't start there
although that's where it all starts with
me
in unless displayed it starts with us
with each of us so I work with buildings
and space and built environments and I
try to understand how the built
environment has affects social dynamics
and I'm especially interested in racial
inequality I focus on the built
environment not only in its form and how
it physically affects things but also
symbolically how people read it what
they read into it and how race is sort
of encoded in built environments today
I'm gonna present on some patterns of
the built environment in the Americas
and focusing primarily on Puerto Rico
but but sort of generalizing to the
Caribbean in Latin America and how they
formulate racial exclusion and how in
kind of performing race the built
environment also formalizes a racial
order that supposes that it's a
democratic system that that race and in
Latin America and the Caribbean is
liberal in it that is rather democratic
so the racial democracy
I guess my book oh there we go so that's
my book locked in locked out where I
examine specifically the production of
gates
public and private housing and how they
do the work of segregating communities
are by physically building race class
and gender inequality in the book I make
a long argument for the ways in which
race is codified in the built
environment and how this violates the
presume that presumably role nature of
the structure of race in Latin America
and the Caribbean the so-called racial
democracy which I am NOT gonna kind of
like go full-on to the description of
race in Latin America and the Caribbean
except to say that there is a sense that
there is an expensive mixture of races
dr. Hernandez some of her work speaks
directly to this and sort of like this
mythic construction of a continuum where
we're all the same and we all have three
we're all African Spanish and and
indigenous and we get along well and
it's not like the u.s. I dr. Landers has
a particularly spoken to also the mythic
creations that are involved in the u.s.
right in producing how the US is also
framed in ways that benefit this
narrative of the racial continuum
domestics aji the rainbow people I'm
sort of discourse so um in my book I
challenge this by looking at the built
environment and so it's hard to know
where where it is and so I look at
privileged gated communities which
scholarship and area communities tends
to look at them sort of like the you
know and how it informs their lifestyle
and this is these are communities in the
city of Pune in Puerto Rico and I
highlight how the form the aesthetics of
the gates and the function the way they
work and who operates them and who
manages them are imbued with meaning of
who belongs inside and who is supposed
to be outside
and with few exceptions most of the
scholarship has sort of like forgotten
that these gates also imagines an
outsider it's sort of like what happens
what's going on what are they doing
inside but also who are they referencing
outside it has been overlooked and but
also that these gates operate in concert
with other types of gate and so I look
also at sorry god these other gated
communities there are some animations
here that I don't you know can figure
out but they weren't supposed to be
there but my book looks closely as this
other side so this is the play unlocked
in locked out right it depends on where
you're standing who you are whether
you're inside or whether you're out so I
look at these other sets of gates and
the gates of quote-unquote the poor now
there's a lot of security station around
working class and of like poor named
poor communities and here I looked at
how these gates in public housing both
again in form in aesthetics but also
physically work to mark the communities
as dangerous not belonging and in need
of being controlled so these are the
gates of the poor and so in the book I
try to kind of tease out the many ways
in which they send this messaging they
create this messaging they're branded as
such and the ways they reproduce
segregation and inequality so
continuously making this contra contrast
between sort of like the right side and
and the left side of those two images
the private a private community and I
look at two private communities and two
public housing communities in the book
now the question is many people
understand this this is a class
discussion this is about class where is
race
is racing there so you may say that
these gates you know are about don't
really point to a racial hierarchy and
that tends to be the reading that is
given in Latin America the Caribbean as
important Rico sort of like is not race
it's class we're just different so so I
actually what I do in the book is invoke
scholars like Diane Harris and others
like Kevin Lynch drawing from the work
of everything Goffman other people like
Jarrell sorrows Glenn Lowry George
Lipsitz Katherine McKittrick to
highlight that race and racial
inequality is also built in it's made
concrete in the built environment so I
say on how is this huh that's the trick
raised hides in plain sight landscapes
are particularly well suited to them
masking of such constructions because
they appear to be completely natural
natural and neutral as well but there
never does architecture and landscapes
are never to us they are always powerful
symbols and containers of cultural
values just as they simultaneously work
to construct culture so I'm really
vested in understanding the built
environment a society that easily sort
of like since the message like this
right that's a door but what kinds of
racializing elements or produce that
construction and under converse how does
it reproduce racial inequality so now I
bring you me because I must make a point
here about epistemology that's me there
I'm a five-year-old there and this is a
picture taking I grew up in Puerto Rico
daughter of immigrant Dominican
immigrant parents to Puerto Rico who had
had multiple migrations within the
Caribbean prior ancestral migrations
within the Caribbean including the
envelope well who knows what the
Caribbean was during their forests or
you know work migrations because they
were sometimes in Dutch islands
sometimes in French islands sometimes in
British islands depending on what era
you're talking about so but growing up
as a black girl in Puerto Rico frames my
analysis and it friends my scholarship
it's impossible for me not to see race
and to see it from an epistemological
Soufan on my fellowmen illogical
blackness and I'm thinking here a phenom
so I first read phenom when I was you
know at the other school that is sort of
rival a rivalry that I really don't you
know because you know I have a different
relationship I'm the first person that
got there in my whole world and universe
probably will be the last you know no
legacies like you know grunge or who do
you support so you know so I'm not
invested in that at all but I had the
fortune of going to the library why no
library and going in there and finding
phenomenon my own and I Redfern on and
phenom told me every single moment I had
had since I had been 5 years old as a
black girl so this is what phenom said
then
at various points the Corporal and this
sounds like crazy words like you know
that schema crumbled its place taken by
a racial epidermal schema nausia that's
when phonon is called out on a trade
mama the Negro that's the translation it
uses the word Negro mama the Negro look
the Negro in the white world the men of
color encounters difficulties in the
development of its bodily schema
consciousness of the body solely on
negating activity it is a third-person
consciousness because it creates a real
dialectic between my body in the world
so the world comes through me in a black
body and she speaks of this triple
consciousness that then medium human is
remaining one florist a cup in there
after letting the reader a triple
consciousness that builds on Dubois the
way we be the voice sort of double
conscious that I'm not only American and
black
I'm Latino so here the triple body is
being destroyed like I have a multi my I
am who I think I am but I'm also who
other people think I am and who other
people think I am is attached to my body
to my racial schema right so I'm not
only it's not only about identity but
it's a racializing identity it's
different it's what they call a
phenomenological right is attached to my
body so I say this is my black latina
epistemology epistemology and I cannot
undo right that that Phenom stopped
being a body started being a black body
right even to the self and I want to
turn it around because often this is
misunderstood and sort of like you know
well can you be out of rays can you and
sort of use this wonderful project
photographic project of inverting the
world right well in which I think this
is a representation of when you
encounter the world as a racial subject
right if you turn it around right and
whiteness what's the other right like
what would that feel like of course this
doesn't fully capture the relationship
because we would have to really think
about the way I encountered the world as
a black girl with white dolls I mean
pretty you know I mean it's not like now
I don't know if you know what the world
was like in 1980 but in 1980 we had no
we had no blood ban that was my world at
least in Puerto Rico so to clarify in
the context of Dominican Republic in the
Caribbean so we must take this into
account we're thinking about racial
inequality and racial knowledge as
racial scholarship because when I looked
at this world of housing that was
supposed to be natural and neutral I
started to I saw race even when it
wasn't articulated but it often was so
this is a picture suppose picture of a
public housing project behind and you
have this got this writer it got though
rhodius Hulya who says I entered as he
enters he talks about going to a funeral
of a famous singer a black singer
it's the funerals Cortijo in the cell in
the 70s well is it 80s 80s actually
early eighties and he says I entered
that governor's den of iniquity the
project's the legendary symbol of all
the criminality on the face of our
beauty as Porto Rico the projects that
anti utopia shares with that miss the
virtue of a meaning that is both blurred
and perfectly clear terrifying in its
concreteness yet
the same time vague he talks about
seeing them in saying they're watching
me too right and they're reading me as a
blanket oh he says this I mean it just
says blanket I was like a a white guy I
think he says blanquito with a with a
with a with a mustache and they're also
seeing me so we're all seeing each other
and although it may not be acknowledged
necessarily this is another picture this
is actually Gordie Howe the who he
attended the funeral the representation
of the Casa Rio which is stunning for
the public housing as a black space
nobody's saying don't hang out with
black people don't go to the casa do
stay out of public housing that's the
space so there's qualified right put up
the gates because they're dangerous stay
out of there
but similarly this sort of natural
neutral landscape of housing shows its
face also on the side of private or
Boniface unis middle and upper-class
communities I don't know if I'll get the
but maybe let's see if this comes out oh
you're not connected to the Internet
okay so I'm not even gonna go there but
I was going to show you just one of the
commercials that was running Professor
Thomas Elias will recognize this but
yeah oh yeah like a seat I now have the
house that I always promised you between
romance and flowers will form a home the
phone the home the home you buy the
mortgage home always comes clad in white
images right often so that those who
live there who exist there are white
other sort of images reflect this this
is an image from 1930 1990s in the
reflection of who's the criminal who's
the dangerous person with
partner who's clearly black you know in
their chat you know sort of like
threatening and Pueblo which is the
public represented I mean it might be a
mixed-race person I mean in in this case
it might be might not that's still sort
of like a polar opposites right with
blackness clearly of the dangerous so
these images are persistent so that's
one way to see it when you look at the
data so if you go looking for it you see
other things you see like interviewed
tend to say we're white or some form of
white mermaids on the public housing
Caesarea side but still rather you know
a slew of people holding out to black
identities some and also mix or other
identities this is based on census
figure when you look at segregation we
see so they get to spend time in white
worlds in the context of Puerto Rico and
then I've done this this kind of
calculation if you were gonna highlight
different characteristics so I look here
at unemployment household income poverty
and different kind of levels of
education towards the bottom and looking
at the differences so these are the
means
white and I don't know they're writing
two more races it's significant lack
another so sort of comparing some to
one-on-one comparisons and what this
shows I mean just look at the white
differences all significant meaning that
in popular in unemployment in household
income in poverty in education there are
differences right so typically whites
tend to be doing better like them to be
worse there are less differences between
for example so white another still many
different sense white and so whites are
completely distinguished from these
other groups and blacks tend to not that
different than others are leasing these
measures in somewhat different from two
or more races people so from the mixed
people which kind of an sort of is an
interesting conversation kind of
dialogue with your findings so the point
I want to make here is that we think of
this racial continuum right I was like
there is who don't know what to classify
but when it comes to thinking about
racial inequality it might be that there
are binaries being imposed right created
so I want to think about race in the
Caribbean and Latin America rather than
in for the purpose of racial inequality
as rather than a continuum as a system
of racial binaries where the line might
be drawn lower or higher depending on
the particular situation certainly
whiteness carries some power right here
as those blackness right so even as we
think of like only about three guys have
to regain your but but you know el-hawa
like where do these other terms fit in
particular situations they move here or
they move there but you know what
they're not going to the top in any kind
of configuration and those we bought the
top are not coming down in any
configuration of the situation again I'm
talking here about social kind of like
dynamics right systemic structural
dynamics rather than like how people
feel or how they identify so
consequences for housing for education
for employment for example so I want I
have kind of like versions of those
situations and how those move but I
won't talk about it things that show up
spatially people try this is for
Kingston this is from the portes and at
our book and Caribbean cities and you
know often these are mapped according to
income the point here is if we know that
income is aligned with race how do you
think this looks and how segregated they
are so if you look at these cities they
are rather segregated there are very few
places that are sort of mix those sorry
going back the mixer are they well there
they didn't do mix here but some of
these have like medium and high income
this is Guatemala I'll just quickly goes
this is not a good map but this one is
not a good image I should say this is a
great map it's just my image is bad but
but but I wanted to highlight it because
Kingston here they do race and color in
here and then you're able to see some of
them just - this is param our Devo which
also shows sort of segregation and here
they do do krill sort of like an ethnic
breakdown of the city what I'm trying to
show here is that if we look for them if
we if we if we understand race and I'm
looking for it I'm looking for it no you
know I'm not gonna make mistakes we see
that there is a racial distribution
right that aligns around in a car
and we can continue to see a different
fabric alone in dominican republic which
was built to celebrate the 500th
anniversary of the of the arrival of
Christopher Columbus to the Americas a
project that took a century to make
happen and and in the federal cologne is
made into a landscape right where you
have to hide the clothes by communities
behind the wall so race is there it's
not only class it's race also that is
actualized in these constructions this
is in Lima Peru interestingly enough and
more oh I love it
la marea Delaware when science and moral
Delaware when Sandy are here is La
Mirada la verga West which separates
sort of irregular they call it
settlements but squatter settlements
from the rest of the city actualized
right I mean just the symbolism we think
of it of all residents of either side of
the wall are so here again we see sort
of like this binary right in the built
form is not like you can live in between
right in the wall or in between but
there are rather stark distinctions
being made between right you know better
or worse good and bad white and black
whatever or non white white black gnome
black here's another a very popular
image it doesn't look that well here it
looks okay but there it doesn't look
that great but actually somebody is
using it for the book very excited about
Google's herons book that uses this
image about Mexican golf clubs but here
it's this is from Brazil Sao Paulo I
believe and it shows this stark
distinction right about between Karanka
favela and
upper-class exclusion but they're
everywhere if you look through security
points who does it
who does it sort of profile who does it
look who is it keeping out who it's not
I'm not gonna play this video but it's a
great video I recommend you look at all
carlos Angulo in colombia going through
the city and noting how he's always
stopped and he gets very pissed off in
this video it's a fantastic video I
highly recommend because four black
bodies in Latin America and Caribbean
they never they're always right it feels
like a binary it feels like that
funonion moment and it's documented okay
I'm just gonna get here and so the
question is if we think if we rethink
this continuum into boundaries how does
it look like so here's the case of
Brazil who was like okay we're gonna do
affirmative action those who are black
there was very low enrollment of black
afro-brazilians in higher education and
they did a formal policy program we're
gonna bring in after a brazilians and
they're gonna in and they're gonna you
know kind of like increase the numbers
what happened suddenly everybody was
black right like all the mixed-race
people were like this is my way in and
so I love these because then they were
like wait a second we have to figure
this out so so as the mixed-race country
grapples with its later Co slavery
affirmative action race tribunals are
measuring skull shape and nose width to
determine who counts as disadvantage
right so we go to this place where we
have to figure out who are the who are
the people that are benefiting or not
benefiting from these racial orders that
are you know kept sort of complex and
hard but that also in their complexity
and and hard to understand reproduce
inequality so
these pots are for people who are phenol
typically back said one history major in
a member of student activist group told
me it's not for people with black
grandmothers and that's the difference
that's what we have to figure out right
how to address blackness in ways that's
responsible to the actual social
dynamics that are reproducing inequality
but in a country as uniquely diverse as
Brazil where 43 percent of citizens
identify as its race Tania and 30
percent of those who think of themselves
as white have black ancestors it's not
immediately clear where the line between
race should be drawn nor who should get
to draw it and using what criteria so if
addressing sorry racial inequality
requires coming to terms with the
structure of rich right the structure
and which those privileges in those
penalties that this are distributed what
do we do then when it's not about
identity oh yeah you can be whatever you
want right but if you walk right when
are you encountered with the
phenomenological right reality of a
racial bodily schema so that's my sort
of one question moving forward and so my
word is trying to say these build
structures you know they're not like you
can tear them down I cannot walk through
the wall I want to walk through the wall
but that's the very same way in which
racial structures exist even if they're
perceived to be invisible and rather
liberalizing so I'll stop there thank
you for listening
[Applause]
so I guess my first question is for both
of you um I guess what are some
challenges in researching anti blackness
through these larger structures space
and law especially when there's a
personal I guess relation to these this
larger topic sorry
so the challenge for the researcher yeah
of the research in like studying
anti-blackness especially in these large
really large structures especially when
there are some personal ties to or
relation to the I guess what I want to
do is respond to that in a very lawyerly
way and what I mean by that is this um
and picking up immediately right where
there didn't say Flores left off right
this idea but oh how does Brazil deal
with affirmative action in this
racialized hierarchy etc well it was as
you put that out there that I started to
reflect back how what the legislators oh
and what many um universities have done
but then there was a federal law that
came down anyway uh that much detail you
don't need but he what they did in
response was incorporate the built
racial constructs right the physicality
of racialization into their affirmative
action policy what I mean by that rather
than only focusing on race identity the
affirmative action cases for a higher
education look at
allocate a significant number of spaces
for those who come from public high
schools know which majority of the way
to lead don't attend and so that
racialized space without having to
engage in this like measuring someone's
head that nonsense right um which sort
of feels very you know the Antebellum
once's Italy's so it takes the built
environment and and this was an IT
excuse me this was an idea of the black
social justice movements I mean their
response to when people say oh well you
know how can you be asking for policies
of social inclusion based on race when
nobody knows what anybody is and we're
still there
and they're like little quip is just ask
her police officer right they always
know right they always know because
they're busy racially profiling and they
figure it out that's you know it's
somewhat little off in a way of
responding but what it encapsulates is
this idea of it's not that complicated
when you become very pragmatic at
looking at the effects of group-based
racialization the indicators are there
right we've saw a beautiful display of
that in his body of research and so yes
it's a challenge but yet only I think
when people and it's outside tomorrow
stop when people overly focus on trying
to sort of understand racism by reducing
it to the personal when it's just only
about you and how you feel in any given
space that's not unimportant but it
doesn't actually illuminate how racism
operates which is unconcerned about your
personal identity and solely focus on
how to racialize you as not belonging
everything you said I think that one of
the challenges that precisely this
concern with sort of like people's
feeling about about it or you know
identity which is heightened for good
reasons often in in the Caribbean and
Latin America setting that you know
we're all one nation and it was attached
to national projects right anti colonial
projects that required sort of like a
tight and and population the challenge
in focusing on that is also that we
don't produce the data we don't produce
the type of information that will allow
us to tease out these inequities and so
you know I do build the environment
and the question is like and that's why
I started talking about this
epistemological piece aside I don't see
race there
raise that's just like you know it in
the same way that when people have
experiences it's like how do you know
that was about race it's like well you
know I mean me yeah I think it was and
you know how do you actually provide the
evidence for it and so I think that
there's also there's also it's probably
not the best word for it but there's a
hegemonic production update that
dictates what data counts and what data
is important
oh sorry
[Music]
city's already in urban cities with one
major people both in terms of
demographics but also how do we read
this binary or certainly the USB so
maybe we can take a couple of questions
and then you guys came together so there
was another question
one of my struggles is one where we call
sadness here
because
very very strong and so I just wonder
and yet you know there is but how how
does it affect even to what we do at
home see reality hill because we don't
what I didn't really love that that's my
that you happy
it's an idiot incorporate language and
there's racism there and there it is you
know so am I just trying to figure out
what are the benefits of that and how he
kind of also be limit or scholarship if
we also just seen
okay and one more and then they can take
it collective okay so then we can and
then well I can be very brief on this
one um I said and I sort of see the two
questions as as related to each other
some sort of one response and then sort
of what is the binding black/white
binary still even relevant today if it
is relevant does it have some negative
influences and that it obscures other
intersections other vectors of in
sources of inequality right
and I think everything we've talked
about today suggests that the binary is
still relevant you don't want to call
black/white if that indicates to you a
sense of only african-american and only
European white then let's rename it I'm
not tied to it right but if what we
understand as blackness and whiteness is
more than just the African American and
European whites and we understand that
the way it operates is about it in out
equal unequal mode of analysis I think
one it's actually very relevant in how
we see socioeconomic status arrayed and
also relevant for analysis and trying to
combat it how then do we deal with so
it's what some might view is a negative
consequence of hiding other vectors of
discrimination welcomed in my world
discrimination we include them right it
it this idea of doing multivariate
analyses for social science evil in your
own right
yes it makes it more complicated but it
doesn't mean that it's impossible you
can look at gender and race you can look
at race and color you know there's lots
of ways to deal with these things and
not have a response that means
oh we've moved beyond and we're so
post-racial that binaries are no longer
in operation because when we get rid of
that
language my fear and we've seen this
sort of before civil rights movements
become in in in Latin America that it is
a form of currency that then undermines
the ability to even voice and name
what's going on allottee right because
to begin with I think to not think of to
think of inequality to not think about
inequality benefits from thinking that
it's complex and hard and yet as you say
like a cop knows and we know what our
prison population looks like right and
we know that communities are being who
benefits sort of like in the rich of
Florida who benefits right from this no
kind of order of the city that is highly
interpretive intrapreneurial is right
who has access to funds who doesn't he
are not suggesting that the binary is
sort of like a ratio schema or only a
racial schema I'm suggesting that
schemas are laid out in binaries in ways
that says who benefits and who is
penalized and so if we think about that
beyond our concern with whether it
represents all of us right like is that
capture my black grandmother as it right
I mean does it capture it well in this
in this instance your black grandmother
is irrelevant right because you might be
able to walk into a place that the
person who is actually you know
themselves black would not be able to
walk so it's sort of like on I'm
thinking about it not as a strict and
that's why I say it's moving and it's
plural right like it's plural in that it
can different situations call for
different things so so that's what I'm
thinking here it doesn't restrict
ethnicity from participating and I'm
writing why are we gonna think it's like
oh you know and let's say a Dominican
in in Puerto Rico we're gonna think we
have to take into account that they're
Dominican if they are if they are if
they blend in into whiteness Puerto
Rican style does that matter in that
instance it likely doesn't you know have
employment let's say if it does if it's
raised as of that's really at the heart
of the sort of like what's going on with
regards to employment then we get at
that right so it's not about sort of
oppression politics or competing kind of
like privileges but what are the
operative kind of dimensions social
dimensions that reproduce inequality and
how thinking of it by narrowly because
it operates right people are excluded or
included how might we use it to address
inequality
[Applause]
[Music]